nous sommes dans le lower east side
bienvenue chez les punks 12
les punks 12 un mouvement artistique
exclusivement judaïque qui s'est lancé
le défi de dépoussiérer la torah
le créateur de cette mouvance c'est lui
isaac shenfeld
aujourd'hui ce juif de 37 ans nous a
donné rendez vous dans une synagogue
unique à new york au nord de manhattan
ici le téléphone portable est autorisé
pendant l'office religieux
à new york il y a des centaines
peut-être mille synagogue mais celle ci
est spéciale super spéciale unique même
il ya plein de points que juif ici je
dirais une dizaine
mais ils sont en train de prier j'ai pas
envie de le déranger
à new york de plus en plus de juifs
comme isaac questionne leur foi
[Musique]
ça c'en est un comme lui ils ont du mal
à se reconnaître dans une pratique
religieuse trop traditionnel l'objectif
des punks 12 moderniser la proche de
dieu leur voie de rédemption l'art
les pains de juifs sont des gens qui ont
grandi dans la tradition
[Musique]
et qui veulent explorer d'autres voies
de leur religion s'ouvrir et retrouver
de la spiritualité
exprimez-vous c'est ça le message pas de
jugement faites ce que vous voulez
fais en sorte d'être bien vous faites
partie de nous vous faites partie de la
communautés
[Musique]
il y à un million de juifs à new york et
trois millions de façon d'être juif
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
l'ong beach au sud de new york
loin de la synagogue c'est dans une cave
qu'isaac retrouve ses amis musiciens et
leur groupe de punk michao y traduisait
le sauveur est un groupe de musique folk
on est juif pratiquant croire achats
monde sans dieu en la torah et on fait
de la musique punk à la télé en france
ils vont dire c'est pour ça qu'on doit
tuer les juifs je prends vous savez les
us open qui on n'a pas besoin d'essayer
de l'être c'est notre seconde nature le
judaïsme a toujours été peint on résiste
depuis 3000 ans pensez bien à ça
une longue barbe une grosse envie
d'hurler mais dans leur texte ni sexe ni
drogue ni rock'n'roll juste deschamps
vieux de plusieurs millénaires tiré de
la torah de la musique 100% punk
[Musique]
nouvelles formes vieux 20 nouvelles
bouteilles on n'essaye pas de réforme et
on veut restaurer nous sommes un
mouvement qui restaure nous revenons aux
bases à l'essence même du judaïsme à new
york
les punks juice ont tous profondément
croyant sur le plan politique beaucoup
plus difficile d'accorder ses violons la
place qu israël doit occuper au
moyen-orient divise au plus haut point
isaac lui est le plus libéral d'entre
eux la plupart des peuples juifs doivent
peut-être pour la création d'un état
palestinien
et bien sûr on croit à la paix avec nos
voisins mais ses amis ont une vision
plus sioniste le futur d'israël je crois
que c'est un seul état avec au centre la
torah oui un seul état indivisible un
autre père pourquoi on ne devrait pas
construire des immeubles des maisons sur
notre propre terre
retour dans lauper east side comme tous
les jeudis c'est soirée cholet ndt le
show dance est le point de ralliement
hebdomadaire des punks 12 new yorkais on
y va on va tous en enfer et il n'y a pas
d'issue l'enfer selon isaac cessa de
jeunes juifs excentrique qui fuient les
synagogues pour faire la bringue au
premier étage ateliers concerts pour
être chaussés ambiance plus studieuse ce
soir un auteur juif présente son dernier
roman
pendant ce temps dans la cuisine
isaac fait la popote voici le show late
un plat traditionnel qui a donné son nom
au soir et ça n'a pas l'air très bon
faut pas faire attention quand on le met
dans le pot c'est dégoûtant
ça c'est le cholet s'est fait avec plein
de haricots de pommes de terre d'oignons
et des pis c est aussi une métaphore
pour les gens ici on se retrouve tous
ensemble chacun est unique et
complètement différent comme les pommes
de terre les haricots et quand on les
réunit le forbin tous complets aimant
positif c'est pourquoi nous sommes le
cholet
c'est ça le melting-pot à la sauce punk
12 un assortiment de personnalités un
mélange de générations et un gros élan
d'amour un câlin c'est ce qu'on veut
montrer ici c'est un environnement où
l'esprit des gens est en vie ils n'ont
pas à regarder la télé pour se divertir
je veux dire qu'ici ils vivent dans un
monde d'idées et c'est très bien comme
ça
la plupart des gens ici ont quitté la
communauté juive et s'ils sont avec nous
ce soir c'est pour retrouver sous
d'autres formes ce qu'ils ont perdu à
new york
isaac et les punks 12 font entendre leur
voix le mouvement commence même à
franchir les frontières
ils ont été récemment aperçue à montréal
berlin et même en terre promise
près de jérusalem
[Musique]